[Music]
good to see you yeah you're wearing the
same shirt you were wearing last time I
have a very limited wardrobe yes we are
now in mid I want you to imagine close
your eyes and imagine we are in
mid-march now we had a very successful
live event although because of some warp
in the space-time continuum we can't
seem to summon the memory of that
experience but it did indeed happen and
we are convening to talk to you guys
today about how to enter the spring
season fair children engaged excited
about your fitness athletic journey well
you made it through the winter right and
you're somehow I'm out of the cave yeah
and it's spring and you're excited that
the work you put in is now starting to
be able to be used outside but if thing
called fresh air and your skin is
actually touching Sun versus being
layered up and well careful though
because March is a very tricky time of
year for people that live particularly
in the Northeast because you think
because it's March that winter is over
but there's still a couple last gasps
the fact the worst snow to get thrown in
your direction before those flowers
bloom yeah we want to go too much false
hope here that's true but that's the
classic scene that you see in late March
on in the Northeast
one day it's 65 Randy and everybody's
house running without their shirts on
Central Park and then two days later
there's a snowstorm god bless him yeah
so yes so we we took your advice Chris
and we got through those winter months
staying engaged as consistent as we
could with releasing our that pressure
that we put on ourselves to be perfect
it's time to go outside it's time to
start thinking a little bit more
precisely about that race that we've got
our eye on or perhaps the one that we're
just now summoning the courage to sign
up for yeah and
spring is on the horizon yeah here we
are
and now it's more about what did i do
over the winter that now will translate
to the outside right and how do I reward
myself with the hard work and the
consistency that I put in and put forth
an event that I'm excited about that I'm
a little bit fearful of that will really
challenge me but then also it's gonna be
fun and I'm really happy on this end of
the winter in this case of having done
the work and now I'm really excited to
go do it like it's now on the horizon
it's six eight twelve weeks away and so
that's powerful now we can feel it now
we can sense where we have the ability
to train for it we don't know we can do
it yet right but we we know we've put in
good time and that we're sort of gonna
have that slingshot effect out of the
winner and push us forward to do
something that we haven't done before
right something scary something exciting
out there what are the mistakes that we
want to avoid well one is dinner bite
off more than we can chew right we've
made it through the hours of the winter
which are always limited and now because
it's the spring and the days are getting
longer we think we'll have more hours
magically available right the schedule
will free up it doesn't work like that
unfortunately as masters athletes so we
want to be careful not to add too many
more hours to our training that we think
we'll be able to do and then that create
a false reality and then in a couple
weeks we're disappointed about what we
just signed up for so maybe it's a 50k
instead of a 50-miler right maybe it's
the next progression from a 50k to a
50-miler but not doing a hundred mile or
a hundred K maybe it's a 70 point three
instead of an Ironman right
again test the waters to see what you're
capable of doing and gradually grow the
schedule versus China all of a sudden
jump into a twenty hour week where all
winter you've gotten really good your
family's gotten good your works gotten
good around this routine and scheduled
that you've created
very diligently around 10 hours and we
don't want to create any type of
animosity in any respect and any part of
the three-legged stool as I say where
they suddenly say well oh now the
trainings really beginning we knew it
here it comes oh hey you don't want that
now you want that gentle syrup all right
you know I'm gonna go out it's earlier
yeah the gradual aspect of it is super
important and I know that I've
confronted this and my own experience of
coming into the spring months excited
about the season ahead and feeling
engaged with my fitness and having to
resist the urge of going harder and
going longer because it's a beautiful
day out right and you've always been you
know reeling me back and reeling me back
against my impulse which is like I want
it I want to go I want to go you know
and I think you know in retrospect
looking back on that that has been
crucial in ensuring that I don't get
injured or I don't get burned out or
overtrained we together were so careful
in my Ultraman training years of of
erring on the side of less to avoid
injury particularly with run volume like
was so careful you know like being very
incremental and diligent about not doing
too much running too soon it's important
again we want longevity right and we
want you to be in this for a while and
in order to build that volume that
foundation ever so gradually the only
way that works is if you're actually
able to do it healthy right and that
keeps you motivated that keeps you
excited it keeps the confidence growing
for your event
and again you're out there doing it so
the more you're out there doing it you
can have your own sensations avoiding
injury is key but also as I was saying
avoiding creating tension around your
training many of us have been in
situations I definitely have been in
situations where I'm out there wondering
what I should be doing at work right now
or wondering actually I should have been
home right now for my
family like this and then we're
compromised we're not gonna have as good
of a training session because we're not
as focused and diligent about it we
might even cut it short and we are still
not better at work and family so now
everything is done only 50% as well as
we could have so a gradual build creates
those those boundaries and accretes that
patients and not tolerance by everything
in your world around you in order to
well in a healthy sustainable way maybe
grow the volume or just do it better
stronger faster smarter in their limited
hours that you do and yeah it requires
we've talked about this before but it
requires a different kind of discipline
the discipline of restraint right which
sometimes at least I know for myself can
be harder than the discipline of going
hard you know like I don't have a
problem getting up early and getting
after it like I'm not challenged in my
motivation with respect to that but I am
challenged in holding back when I feel
good or when I have the free time yeah
on this particular day but it's not in
my best interest
physical preparation wise to you know
let that horse out of the barn yeah you
I mean you touched on two things that
one is absolutely there are days in the
schedule where I tell all my athletes if
you have more time today today's a good
day for that right you've had with the
week leading up this is an endurance
week we're over we're adding extra
volume low intensity all this week to
get extra hours in so there's times for
that there's other times absolutely when
we need to show restraint but the first
part that you said is I feel good today
I want to go harder
that's very most often actually a bad
idea because there's an intent and a
purpose for that workout and blowing it
out just because you feel good now
compromises many workouts down the road
no but it feels so it feels so good it's
a temporary hit yeah and then you pay
the price down the road whereas we have
maybe a workout in 3-4 days where it's
way more important to do that intensity
to do that harder effort to
that higher speed and by blowing it out
today because it felt so good is never
the ideal answer where I want to see how
that fits into the bigger picture well
I'm lucky enough to have somebody like
you to hold me back or to hold me to a
certain kind of plan most people don't
have the luxury of working with a coach
so for the people that are listening who
have a goal a fitness goal race they're
preparing for some kind of challenge who
are out there trying to figure it out on
their own how do you how can you counsel
them to best navigate these treacherous
waters of trying to figure out what's
best on a particular day to do yep for
much of that I have them I always
suggest write down your intentions for
the week ahead
one long bike one short bike one
high-intensity bike let's say one long
run one short run one high-intensity run
so that you have a skeleton for the week
of what you want to accomplish and then
a lot of times how you schedule that
depends on a your own life schedule
let's say maybe the weather but also how
you lead into the week of well I need
that everybody knows for intensity that
can't be completely shelled and
exhausted so once you put that intention
into it and you've done that a few weeks
in a row or a few times or you've seen
it's done successfully then you get
better at sort of putting that skeleton
together for yourself
and as we've talked about before with
regards to a journal you know then okay
last time after an intense workout I
needed two days so that I actually
enjoyed the workout again that long run
or that long ride I mean there's so many
athletes that I come across in training
logs where they wonder why they were
cranky and didn't enjoy their long ride
because they shuffled the week around
and put the high-intensity the day right
for a long ride and then they're just
miserable right and now you're out there
for four or five hours on a bike and
you're already tired the first few pedal
strokes it just sets you up for not
enjoying the training as much as you can
as well as as it shouldn't be because
some of the best athletes in the world
they love their training the way it's
structured because they they know their
body's responding to each one of them
and they feel good doing it mm-hmm what
are the are there like resources that
you can point people towards who are
attempting to get ready for a certain
kind of race like I'm just thinking I'm
trying to live in the mind of somebody
who's kind of new to all of this like
doesn't even really necessarily know
what periodization is or even how to
approach why why one long ride a week
and not to you know like just the very
basics of how to approach whether it's
an obstacle course race or a 5k or you
know the twenty nine zero twenty nine or
something brand-new where do people
where can people just learn the
fundamentals about how to approach these
sorts of challenges a lot of it can be
found online right then a lot of in
publications magazines even books are
out there you know my first 5k my first
Olympic distance triathlon my first
trail run things like that um and then
it becomes important to truly listen to
your body to see how your body responded
to that super simple plan and the other
thing there is even with the most simple
plan you want to see how your body
responds to it how it feels to it and
not hold yourself to that exact well on
Thursday it says to do this right it's
okay like see how your body and your
schedule and your life responds to it
and just continue to grow from there so
let's say it has four hours in the first
week of training right for 30-minute
workouts with a couple of stretching
exercises and so forth well you don't
have to do that exactly the way they say
it just take the basic ideas and grow
with it and eventually you might get to
a point where you're actually adhering
100% to it to a to a short a week or
something like that but again keep
yourself from judging yourself too
harshly on how you're progressing in
your own exercise in your own training
it's yours and it's your own special
time so use that to say this is my
intention for today this is what I'm
looking to get done and I will do my
best
to get it done yeah I think that sound
advice I mean one of the things that I
had to learn in my swimming career you
know when you're young you progress very
rapidly right and like every week you
can go faster in the pool then you could
the week before and you have a similar
experience when as a master athlete you
get involved in a new sport like
triathlon or long-distance running
something you've never done before you
can see pretty quick results but at a
certain point that curve is going to
taper a little bit and you have to get
used to the fact that you're not going
to be you can't like go hard every day
you're not going to get a PR every
workout and mentally I think that can be
a challenge for somebody who's new to
this thinking like well I'm not getting
better or trying to understand that
every workout has a purpose and those
purposes are not always going to be
they're not it's not about like going as
fast as you can or breaking the ceiling
on your last performance yeah yeah it's
like a puzzle right I mean some puzzle
pieces are nice the outside pieces they
really fit nicely and you can see what
the puzzle is going to look like right
based off the outside edges but then
these individual puzzle pieces that you
put into this thousand-piece puzzle they
might not mean anything but they're a
critical component to what the puzzle
will look like the image will be when
it's done and that's a lot how workouts
work right those puzzle pieces they have
to fit right there otherwise it's not
going to fit into the picture that
you're gonna end up with in the end and
our first race is in our first few
months in doing any type of athletic
endeavor are those edge pieces they fit
nice yeah see the outline of what its
gonna look like and you feel really good
having completed that outside edge of a
puzzle but then the hard work begins all
the individual pieces that sort of you
start the grind of those little pieces
that have to fit together that make no
sense mm-hmm and I think also when
you're new and you don't know anything
you're going to be more likely to want
to adhere to whatever program you got
off the
net or in some book because you don't
know yeah anything different but as you
progress if you are doing the journaling
and that kind of introspective work of
connecting with yourself to really gauge
how you feel and and how this is working
for yourself you can slowly begin to
take more and more ownership of that
trajectory so you can kind of go
off-script yeah i'm time to time and
experience what it's like to push the
edge here hold back here and gauge how
your body responds yeah and you'll know
your body well enough that you know I'm
overdoing it today but I know the next
two or three days I'm going to pay for
it and I'll go easier and I know enough
about my body I've learned from it I
know how to listen to it and it works
out well like this right I mean a lot of
athletes trained by the weather right
because let's say they're outside
athletes they don't have treadmills or a
gym membership so today it's gonna rain
well I'm gonna run today I want to swim
because I don't want to be out on the
bike in the rain or it's sunny tomorrow
so I'm gonna do my long ride tomorrow it
actually doesn't fit that well but
they'll modify well enough through the
week in order to get it done right and I
tell a lot of my athletes the first step
is to get the week done how it's written
right that's idea in a perfect world but
then beyond that get the totals of the
week done alright shuffle around make
sure the order is not too much quality
in a row but if you can get the sixteen
hours done like that versus how I wrote
it that's fine as long as we keep the
principles of not too much quality in a
row and then we start pulling out pieces
if they can't even make that right what
it's like all right let's take that easy
run out of there and just to make it a
complete rest day let's take that easy
swim out of there make it a complete
rest day or sleep in that morning so
that you're just getting the four or
five critical workouts in for that week
because again at the end of the day it's
about all right we're successfully still
moving forward getting the key concepts
in and then next week when life frees up
a little bit and there's less stress on
us then we'll get in at all we'll get it
all in again right I say so often
training should not
an additional stressor in your life
right you do this to get away from
stresses to exhale to de-stress and
connect with yourself and self-care and
go inside
so if training creates the stress you're
not gonna have that outcome and over
time you're gonna avoid that stress and
then you're not working out oh that
explains how I've navigated winter I
mean we were joking at the outset about
you know nice to see you again because
we're taping back-to-back episodes it's
actually November 27th the same day we
taped the last Coaches Corner and yeah
no I wanted to take this opportunity to
kind of talk about what this experience
has been like for me
and to talk about kind of what you're
getting ready for this year because I
made a conscious decision to not race
this past year to focus on other areas
of my life that I felt needed my full
attention or more of my attention I
should say because to train intensely
towards a specific fitness or race goal
would I knew well enough would create
more stress than then I could manage at
the time given my other goals in my life
and so I just said I'm not I'm not gonna
put that pressure on myself I've stayed
engaged with my fitness but it certainly
hasn't been structured or formalized in
any way and I'm happy with that decision
because I've made a lot of progress in
other areas of my life that I wanted to
to be focused on but I'm also not you
know I like it when I feel super fit I
like it when I'm ready to go and I miss
that and I'm anxious to get back to that
I'm putting a book in front of him right
now that is sort of where your
expectations need to maybe be adjusted
knowledge right like you can you don't
have to win these events or be at the
top or represent as your old self to
still take part in organized events did
I give you the impression that I
was delusional I just I just know you're
an athlete through and through and for
you to put challenges out there you have
been successful in the past with getting
it done and I know you you add extra
pressure of with your life schedule and
so forth but it doesn't have to be quite
on switch off switch and your off switch
doesn't mean you're not doing anything
it means you're still running and
cycling occasionally and of course
swimming but where you work
progressively towards something there's
a healthy medium yeah tween right this
is what this is what is eluded me my
entire life and spills over into every
facet of how I live which is trying to
find a way to approach these things in a
more balanced way where I can where I
let go of that because I have this thing
where it's like I don't want to show up
at a race unless I'm a hundred and ten
percent and that's just yeah it's ego
it's it's a whole number of things and
that's my that's the bigger mountain to
climb then to Train super hard for a
race that for the one you want to lean
into that's gonna make you uncomfortable
well it's super uncomfortable show up
like oh I only trained I'm at 60% and
I'm still I would most of them the vast
majority exactly right so I think
there's an opportunity there for
something where you might want to
explore that oh yeah I know this is what
this is what yeah this is this is what I
wanted to talk to you about
yeah and that's where it becomes
interesting to where it's like you know
what as I've said in the past helping
you navigate through that schedule we've
tested it a little bit a few tire and
also for a tell oh we definitely did
test it but again we had a vision of how
well we wanted to do we wanted to
represent well and so forth we had
talked about that but I think there's a
space there where we can have you fit
enough that you feel really good about
who you are competing at that given
event and I said to you earlier I would
never put you into a environment where
it's the super measure like everybody
like robots competing the event that's
not who you are but something that you
feel
challenged by that you respect but also
that you feel really fit and good about
going into not your best right and you
know you in the past would have done
more but you go you know what this is
who I am now this is the fittest I can
be given my life my age my circumstances
my schedule in the now yeah right and
that is the one I want to explore I know
it's like I just get uncomfortable even
talking about it because it's like I am
the on/off switch guy whether it's doing
the podcast or writing a book or being a
parent like I liked I go all in on one
thing everything gets blocked out and
it's not a good no lc8 recipe there's a
lot on the periphery that can be really
really exciting and fun and beneficial
because that's what they say about in
that book Drive Daniel pink oh yeah yeah
he talks about when we reward and focus
motivationally on one thing we miss a
lot of the opportunities that come along
with it on the periphery and this is the
same thing for you
where you might be surprised how good
you are when you're asked to apply all
your fitness knowledge strategy
intelligence to do the event versus just
knowing you've trained out Rangers the
others right and I think your knowledge
and your experience and doing this for
many many years I think you'd be
surprised how much better
you'd be then what you think you would
not be right at the event as well as how
much you would enjoy it because without
any pressure without any type of like I
can only be Who I am here at this
starting line right and that'd be fun
that is yeah it's weird how I interpret
that as a greater challenge than to go
all-in on a preparing for a race because
that I know how to do that's like I
understand ourselves yeah right we
actually it's a younger version but it's
also it's a mentality thing right and
you as an Olympian like if I say
you Chris you're gonna go to this race
but you're only allowed to train you
know eight eight hours a week yeah you
know I've done a few trails like that
uh-huh right falling into the anonymity
of the field is there's something very
liberating about that right and
completely let go you can completely let
go and we steal your body just sort of
exhaling and absorbing the day and it
was it was the same thing with Attila
for us right I had an amazing experience
at a tillow
when we had to walk a lot well I forced
you to let go it's the effect addition
what we still I in I experienced that
day totally different than if we had
been with blinders on in the whole time
right and I've had quite a few
adventures like that where it's like had
I just tried to grind it out from the
very beginning I would have met the
people I've met right 29 oh 29 I did
that event right in Utah one of the best
experiences about that I should describe
what it is yeah it's basically they rent
out a resort for a weekend and the
challenge by the 29 29 group it's a it's
Jesse its lawyer who's been on the
podcast a couple times yes his company
and he's got a team and they ran out
these mountains and exaggerate these is
the snow basin in this and so you hike
up the mountain from the base to the top
and they take the gondola down and you
save your legs like that it's brilliant
and you bet get to ascend to whatever
mountain top you designate all the way
up to Everest versus 29 0 20 not exactly
and so I did that event in August of
this past year and sure could I have
done all 13 a sense I think was 13 or 16
a sense yes but I chose not to because I
wanted to get to meet the people going
off the mountain every single time they
weren't famous athletes they weren't you
know they hadn't trained for it they put
themselves completely into a vulnerable
place and tried one mmm and then two and
then four or seven or ten
cents and getting to meet those people
out there and taking my time and having
nice conversations with them was
incredibly meaningful to me and I still
get emails from people thanking me and
that it was a great time because we got
to connect as humans as we were doing
this endurance event that's cool
I'm so bummed I wasn't able to go yeah I
really would have it was like to have
gone I definitely want to go to I think
he's got two of them coming up in 2019
Lamont in Utah what's really cool about
it is because you take that gondola down
you save your legs you save your joints
your quads don't hurt the next day
nothing the part that well for you
because I know a lot of people who went
and thought well this is gonna you to
take the gondola it's not how hard can
it go long and it has our glutes because
it's so steep at times that you're
hunched over sort of hiking up pushing
on your knees and legs to get up so but
it's different than the pounding of
downhill versus distress of uphill right
but it's a well very well run event
completely supported a lot of motivation
really cool unique things that they do
about it and they create like a village
at the base right stay in tents or
something like that in these great yurts
they're super comfortable sort of pretty
plush yeah it's glamping at its best and
yeah and then meals and all that and
every time you come down the gondola you
stamp your name on a brain with a
branding iron your name or the the logo
of the event next to your name of each
time ascent you've made uh-huh and so
when you get to the top you get a
special Jersey for the final ascent and
everybody cheers you on it's really well
run it's it's a fun event yeah and where
did he do panels and things like that
were you part of that yeah yeah well we
were part of a nutrition panel mindset
panel training panel and all that that's
cool so that was a lot of fun but again
it was one of those events where you can
come in not have a lot of training and
really exceed your expectations on what
you're capable of because you're with
people who will want to just see what
they're capable if you're not alone
you're not vulnerable you're not
berest you can just go do there's people
who did one there's people who ran
sixteen of them or 13 of them and so
there's the whole spectrum of athletes
but everybody gets cheered and just
definitely unique was calling o brady at
that one no he wasn't
i know he did one of our probably uh
that vermont one the first yeah no mass
no mass so he is as we speak
traipsing across Antarctica unassisted
talk about a curated adventure yeah i
mean he doesn't stop I mean the guide
like you know broke the explorers Grand
Slam World Record and then went into
some other crazy speed record thing and
then went straight to Antarctica like
it's like that's Aviva but of course
that's an extreme example but this is
what I like to get a probably the most
extreme yeah yeah but what how everybody
has a new normal waiting for them right
you might be off the couch doing your
first 5k you've done the 5k and now you
say okay I can do that the new normal
becomes let me go for a 10k let me go
for a half marathon you look back and go
5k right that so your new normal just
continues to shift now of course like
you were talking about earlier we all
reach plateaus where the improvements
aren't that dramatic but our new normal
is constantly moving our new normal with
regards to nutrition with regards to
mindset with regards to distances
through training hours there's new
normals happening all the time
meditation how we how we go about it the
time we spend meditating three minutes
used to be impossible now you can do 20
minutes right now for an hour or just
wander off so that's part of what I
really like to tell a fleet sand people
that I talk to on a daily basis is
create your own new normal right and
that's the beauty of training that
you're creating a new normal and that
new normal then becomes applicable in
all these other areas of your life
because it expands your concept your
perception of what you're capable of and
once you crack that door open in a
physical sense in an
athletic sense you become more amenable
to the idea that you can break barriers
in your professional life you can have
better relationships it's it's just it's
incredible the applicability of what you
learned not just skill wise but just
mindset wise and how that can improve
your life bleeds into all areas of our
life and that confidence and the ability
to motivate yourself to go do something
that you had an intention to do is
phenomenal right it's truly what makes
us human beings okay there's not a lot
of other beings on this planet that set
forth to do something and then
methodically go about doing their either
instinctually doing it or they learn it
in a different way but not not like we
do as humans and so again it's a unique
trait that I would want everybody to
learn about and take advantage of what
is the challenge what is something that
scares me and how can I go about
learning internally and externally
physically and mentally as I'm on that
journey towards that adventure mm-hmm
what are you excited about personally
this year in terms of your own what have
you signed up to do what are you getting
ready for well I have its November 27
yeah on December 1st I find out if I got
into western states oh wow ticket out
there huh I have a very very low you've
never done that before they're done
right I've always wanted to do it but I
have not stuck with my entries every
year and so I reset the clock zone I
only have a 2% chance to get him
where's if you continue to put in every
year then you're you know it's a montage
that I library goes up right so very low
chance but as a backup on the same exact
weekend I set up that I'll do a last
command which is an iron distance race
but more extreme location 48 degree
water you start at 3:30 in the morning
longest day of a year January you know
the longest weekend day of brayer when
you swim two point four miles in that
water then you bike it's a little bit
over 112 113 miles uphill to
Mountain on the other side of the sewer
Bay and then yeah then you climb then
you run up a mountain for 27 months yes
similar to Norseman yeah exactly it's
part of the series and just this year
they introduced that Norseman is now the
world champion qualifier these are all
qualifiers for Norseman for world
champion Jesse okay so Championships of
what extreme and crazy triathlon so they
now have ten or eleven of them there's a
lot of you have Canada man they're the
last command there's why man oh man I
felt like I did Celtic man and all kinds
of Swiss man hunger oh man I mean I've
athlete sending me examples of extra
eyes from the whole world I'm like I'm
that I'm good I'm staying in the same
time zone in Alaska I just remember
watching a video of Norseman was it Tim
de boom yeah one that year and I just
was the most epic yep thing yeah super
hard yeah Tim Tim is he made that race
quite famous yeah because of cuz that
was when he was winning Hawaii Iran and
so we went off and did that or just
right after it and anyone that created
this huge curiosity around again
adventurous Ironman so you know I've
done 38 40 I don't know how many more
Iron Man's in my life and so I'm ready
to try a different type of Ironman so
and you you this past weekend was
Ultraman did you follow that at all you
were free yeah would you be operating
again you put in again yeah hopefully if
she sees my name on there know how you
do one of the qualifier ultraman's oh
like I can't see senator I I would say
no and this is why because again like we
talked about life's busy schedule I'm
not gonna set myself up for success with
work and family by training for two of
these mmm in a row right I just know
myself and I know the tax it'll put on
my direct community work life family so
forth that for me to do that would be
asking too much
yeah and I also know my body quite
honestly I'm
doing this for a long time and to go
through two of those training cycles in
a matter of a year would be a lot I mean
I could defer to the following year
let's say you do an Ultraman in 2019 it
automatically qualifies you for 2020 but
that means doing two years of this type
of training and there's other adventures
I want to do you're so well suited to
that race though yeah you know I would
really love to see you uncork it on that
Cordell but I'm gonna be 50 next year
that's all right man I'm not getting any
younger
nothis are and those guys are getting
faster yeah the guy won this year is 33
I think but I think I'm like mera
Krieger was up there again he still ran
under seven hours and he's like 55 or
something like that by now see those
guys do a good doe at that distance yeah
because they've done it a few times like
marrows but he goes every year yeah so
that's he knows the course he knows how
he needs to train for it is sort of like
me for Ironman right last year I was
able to just go do Whistler out of my
training and I didn't I wasn't in the
fittest place of my life but again I've
done enough of them or I can navigate my
what my energy for ten hours well enough
that I'll know where I am at the finish
yeah all right should we talk about
nutrition a little bit sure what is your
general guidance on in life or for the
training well for the training training
specific people are like what do I eat
what do I eat when I ride my I mean I
get this question all the time what do I
you want to ride my bike what do i what
do you bring with you when you go
running yeah that kind of stuff
well biking and running are gonna be two
different things right because of the
stress on the stomach biking Uranus sort
of smooth air situation without the
rattling and the bouncing and the
jumping around so I often say Clif bars
or something like that something solid
I'm a big believer in solids as much as
I can on training rise I'll actually and
make little sandwiches even and things
like that fruit and little sandwiches
because my body will be able to process
that and the intensity isn't that high
that I need to have anything sugary or
to glucose base right that's just gonna
go glycogen
he's right into my line for shorter
intervals and cycling classes and ninety
minutes or less
I rarely take any food so what do I
recommend I recommend that athletes
create a stomach and a habit that they
know that they're suited to take on all
kinds of different foods because
something will always go wrong right so
if you think you're great every weekend
after an Ironman I get a race report
from somebody that says I thought I was
fine on Clif bars or our bars but after
seven of them you had another one down
or after four of them or whatever and so
I want my athletes to have as much range
as possible from it I've had this shot
that the the gels I've had the shoes
I've had the bars I've had the potato
chips I've had the Oreo cookies I've
tried it all and I've narrowed it down
to a plate of food that I know I can
bring to any race that's what we can't
afford to test and train all the
possible foods that you have a good list
of items that you know you're safe with
me you can find anywhere in the world or
bring anywhere in the world and have a
successful nutrition plan I have this
thing where I've eaten so many bars over
the years that just thinking about
eating a bar right now like it makes me
like I've gone more and more to just
real food you know because it's like I
can't handle the sugar or I don't know
what it is but like I have this
Pavlovian kind of reaction when you
start talking about like that
performance nutrition stuff
that's a great example of what happens
because you pushed you went over the
edge thinking I must eat more Clif bars
for your events whether it was for epic
5 or for Ultraman that's why I want a
fleets this when they're done with it to
stop it because you're gonna be more
successful with fueling over a long
period of time if you eat up until when
you can of that type of food and then
move on to another option because we
want calories in you you need to fuel
right on average I tell people 200 ish
calories 150 to 200
calories an hour for women and 200 to
250 calories an hour for men during
cycling and running events right so that
adds up over many hours I think that's a
cliff bar now or right there but again
you want to have a good knowledge of a
variety of foods that work for you and
that way you can sort of open that
special needs bag that has options in it
you can get to a race at an ultra run
where they have anything from potato
chips the Smarties the M&Ms to peanut
butter and jelly sandwiches all around
there right so that you can take in food
that you need and I agree with you all
the sugars no matter how much somebody
has a sweet tooth or they say they'll be
fine at some point your body just stops
your tastebuds say no more I was granted
Iron Man and then I got to mile 18 I
couldn't stop barfing
like I had 50 gels yeah over the last 12
hours is like but then there's winners
and there's a fleets out there and
they're not just saying that for their
sponsors they truly do 25 jun 30 joules
are able to and so nutrition is the
ultimate and plus one right that where
you are the only sample if you know what
works for you and you've tested in a
variety of temperatures and conditions
and intensities that you know your
palate and how it's gonna work for many
hours 10 to 30 hours then stick with
that you can't test enough I mean no you
can't over state how important it is to
constantly be experimenting in your
training with this even the very very
best the most elite of athletes
endurance athletes out there run into
problems when they you know miscalculate
it because of whatever external reason
and have issues so the more the better
in terms of that experimentation but I
think also it's worth noting I'm
interested in what you think about this
yeah I know that when I go out on the
trails around here I see so many people
who I know they're not they're out on a
they're going out for 45 minutes or
something like that and they've got
their vest and they're just loaded to
the gills with all kinds of bottles and
you know it's it's like
I need all that stuff somebody's the
marketed to you to convince you that you
can't leave your house without literally
enough nutrition to survive for a
weekend yeah well in some cases I'm not
saying this is all the cases in some
cases they might be testing weight
fairness that with the gear that they
want to do because I'll have my athletes
do that too but not with the food I'll
have both water bottles in there for
weight right because for long endurance
events you got to get used to that self
supported way but yeah there is also
this industry brain feeding right where
they've told us you need to eat eat eat
eat and drink drink drink drink and
electrolytes electrolytes electrolytes
and salt salt salt and people overdo
that dramatically you're right
Killian told me he goes out for seven or
eight hours without anything that makes
my head explode as it goes weak because
others will hear this yeah I know it and
then think that that's okay and you can
he is trained his bond of course just go
without food I had a coach way back in
the day he he asked me to go out for two
three hour bike rides not eating that at
all he wanted to build up the tolerance
that you can go on less luckily I got
away from that theory because that is
completely not true our body needs fuel
to operate and even at the lower
intensities where you're burning
primarily fats you will technically have
enough storage on your body for about a
thousand days of exercise without food
but you can't utilize that and your
intensity is way slower and so no it
don't go out for seven hour runs without
food right and the other interesting
thing that you said is that the palate
also changes over the years so what you
might have liked five years ago and
needed changes as you become thinner and
stronger and do different distances or
even the same distance what worked for
me five years ago in an Ironman I no
longer eat that I have to completely
turn mine upside down because it was
too much then I went to too little and I
had up it again you're constantly
testing like you said let's talk about
swimming yeah so this might get granular
for people that aren't interested in
this but if you're listening in you're a
triathlete or you're interested in a
swim run or becoming a master swimmer I
think it is worth spending a few minutes
talking about this because the most
common thing that that you hear I know I
hear I'm sure you do is people who are
interested in exploring this world of
multi-sport but they didn't grow up
swimming they don't really know how to
swim all that maybe you know they may
know how to swim in general but have
never put themselves in any kind of
competitive swim environment and it's
very intimidating and I think it scares
a lot of people away from a sport that
they might enjoy if they could wrap
their head around a way of you know
learning how to get comfortable in the
water
I love master swimming programs from
that aspect because you get some
coaching and there's a social aspect of
it and there's a structure to it there's
many choices usually during the week to
get in the pool and it's not like these
are all former and CWA swimmers you know
at every masters workout it's
intimidating though it's scary if
somebody who's never done anything like
a saloon but so is doing anything else
right and having an embracing warm
community that all started as beginners
at some point maybe not the n-c-double-a
guys at the far end of the pool who
don't even remember when they learned
how to swim but in every master's
program I've ever come across there's
always a few swimmers who you can see
they just started a couple months ago
mmm and you'll swim with them and
they'll be open to having you in their
lane and growing from there as a swimmer
and you get instruction with it - yeah
it takes a little bit of courage though
to kind of walk through that door I mean
I remember when I first was thinking
like maybe I want to do a triathlon and
I was terrified to just walk in the door
of helens bikes which is like kind of a
high-end bike shop here in Los Angeles
and I'm like I swam it's damp like I'm
an athlete and I was like I didn't know
the questions to ask and like you know
those guys in there they're all they're
pro cyclists or whatever it's very it's
it's very long the sports like that are
intimidating when you walk into most of
those shops probably trail running the
least because they're sort of pretty
chill pretty chill anyway yeah but um
triathlon and cycling on swimming for
sure and the aspect was swimming is that
I mean you have a evolutionary response
to drowning right and a fear of that so
it makes sense and that's why I would I
always recommend a master's program
where you can stand and take your time
and not be intimidated because of what
they're doing but more because you're
comfortable just being there and that's
the social aspect right where people
just are having fun yeah I think beyond
that though it's important to make sure
that you're getting instruction like a
lot of masters coach they're they're
they're they're creating a workout but
sometimes there isn't a lot of
individual attention so I think it's if
this does intimidate you or you feel
like you really want to progress to find
somebody who can give you some
one-on-one yeah because there's nothing
like having somebody just look at your
stroke and and give you a couple things
to work on and then a couple weeks later
give you a couple more things to work on
because you really can only master one
or two tweaks at a time and generally
somebody who doesn't have a background
in this will have 20 things wrong with
what they're doing and you got to really
take it step by step and be patient with
with it
I think the biggest mistake that most
inexperienced swimmers and triathletes
make is they're so worried about their
conditioning and their fitness that they
just want to get in the water and swim
back and forth certain amount of time to
feel like they got a workout in the
window watch to make sure that they get
in yeah exactly there's no structure to
the workout there's no real
intentionality behind it
and at the same time they're not working
on their fundamentals or their stroke
technique in such a way that that they
would be better off just scrapping that
whole program and starting from zero and
spending you know three months on
nothing but drills to perfect their
stroke because they're fighting the
water they're inefficient they're
creating all this resistance they're
expending all this energy they don't
need to because they don't understand
how to make the water work for them yep
there's levers in that water for us yeah
to make us work work less and swim
faster there's also a few programs out
there I really like the swim smooth
program under devouring how to swim they
have animation and so a lot of it that
you can swim on your own and then you
have certified swim smooth coaches
around the country in the world in this
case who you then concession at
scheduled video sessions with and
one-on-one time with and what's really
cool about those swim smooth certified
coaches that's a lot to say is that
they're often they run a master's
program on the side any way that you
could join or they'll know where you can
find a program to work with but again
like you were saying seeing yourself
swim and then working with animation and
then getting one-on-one instruction
combined all three of those you're gonna
learn a lot quicker than just on your
own
yeah and it's different from running or
riding a bike it really is technique
driven it's much more like learning how
to swing a golf club than it is how to
ride a bike I compared swimming the way
we swim in the pool
a lot to track running the times are
shorter just like that in 40 SEC's 60
seconds and most the time for a track
athlete at the track is drills warming
up stretching doing a few short bursts
and then being done and focused 100% on
technique and swimming a similar warm-up
variety drills a main set with some
bursts and efforts and then warmed out
focused on technique all the time
and so you wouldn't go to a track if you
want to be a 400-meter runner and just
run 400 meters over and over and over
again at a slow speed you want to have
variability and drills and bounding and
strength and explosiveness and drills
all built into that workout and similar
and swimming and if you're not coming
from a swimming background and you're
interested in triathlon you have to
understand that you don't need to go
fast and you're not going to be
competitive anyway because you didn't
grow up with the sport so you need to
forget about all of that and understand
that the goal or the priority should be
getting out of the water feeling good
learning how to swim efficiently enough
so that you are moving forward in the
water with some degree of you know
aptitude and efficiency but that you're
getting out excited about the next stage
yeah you're not gonna be in the front
pack you know forget about all of that
kind of stuff which I feel most most
don't have that expectation but they do
have an expectation that it would go
better or come up there's a different
strategy but you would have won the
amount of time you would have to put
into it doesn't make sense and
ultimately it doesn't matter because the
swim the way triathlon works with the
exception of Ultraman the swim is almost
irrelevant yep it's a means to an end I
call swimming the first part of a
triathlon it's a longer warmup it's a
means to an end it's designed to get you
from the starting gun to t1 and nothing
else right and so if you can get through
this wimba ficient lee using the least
amount of energy but still in the time
that you wanted to in order to then have
a more significant bike and run that's
the goal
uh-huh right and a lot of swim coaches
and this is my biggest issue I don't
have a lot of issues with swim coaches
but my biggest issue with swim coaches
is that they teach triathletes how to be
swimmers versus triathlon swimmers or my
open water swimmers and there are clear
differences between the two right one is
more shorter speeds
shorter bursts in speed for hundreds and
meters let's say that's a total of six
minutes yes maybe whereas if you're
getting ready for 30 40 50 an hour and a
half worth of swimming it's a different
workout right I don't need you to
perfect your your butterfly backstroke
and Bastian brushstroke I don't need you
to have good streamline off-the-wall and
tube dolphin kicks off the wall
I don't need your flip turns to be great
if you're gonna do open water swimming I
need you to be able to get through that
efficiently like you said in order to
have an effective bike and run and to be
able to maintain your equanimity and
your composure in a stressful situation
where there's people kicking you in the
head and there's a lot of chaos to be
calm and relaxed yep yep and to
understand how to cite you know you have
to be able to raise your head and like
see what you're going see where you're
going
you often dragged along by a lot of
other swimmers when you're in the middle
of the pack so you sort of know that
part okay you just sort of follow all
the minnows mm-hmm but the the part of
being comfortable when you sit when you
swim is also important because wetsuits
can feel incredibly restricting and a
lot of athletes get a great athletes get
panic attacks anxiety and almost have to
stop the swim because they have
shortness of breath and the whole thing
and what I always say there
understanding the dynamics of a wetsuit
is very very important because a dry
wetsuit the liner hasn't gotten what yet
to absorb the moisture so that it
properly stretches and sticks to your
skin and can become a second skin when
it's dry it's just a tight elastic suit
constricting your breathing around your
neck and everywhere on your arm body
and it's pressure on your body and we
have a response to that same as when we
hit the water everything ceases in
general it's a it's a response of our
way back of our great ancestors that can
make the swim in the beginning very very
panicky I still have not used two
wetsuits that cover the shoulder like
unless it's freezing and we're in Sweden
like I would rather have a sleeveless
like that restrict
around the shoulders like I just cannot
acclimate to that you know I've never
swum without them because I love that
extra point by arms yeah what do you
think is the future of of Ironman you
know when you look at these races
there's so many of them now they sell
out a year ahead of time thousands and
thousands of people and and you see
these clips on the Internet or if you
track this stuff we're all its they're
just massive packs of people it looks
like a giant drafting peloton I mean
what is going on the sport has
definitely changed and it's becoming
every man's sport the uniqueness of an
ironman and a 70.3
has definitely shifted it's still quite
unique but I think Ironman in general
knows that the customers it's getting a
certain type of person and when I say
the customer I'm talking repeat
customers ones they do it for many years
and I think Ironman and their parent
company is completely happy and fine
with that they're not willing to spend
the dollars or investments in order to
grow that they have a very religious
following in that space and everybody
else is sort of on the periphery they do
it once or twice and then they either go
on to other adventures or they move on
to something else
mmm right and so the future I think is
those people who are already in it and
love it and are religious about it
they're gonna continue to accept those
price increases and that drafting type
of racing because that is what it is
it's their sport but I think that is now
going to be challenged with future
generations of young athletes who now
have a lot of options absolutely in
terms of what they want to specialise in
and what they want to explore an
experience whereas the people that are
kind of from our age bracket and above
it was iron iron man was it that way
ultra endurance
there was a cultish sort of allegiance
to this and
and you know a fervor around these races
that created a lifestyle for a lot of
people which isn't great you know an
amazing thing but I you know if you're a
24 year old aspiring endurance athlete
or you know a young even younger
now you look you can canvass this
landscape and there's so many options so
what is that adventure how does that
bode for Ironman 20 years from now in my
personal opinion I don't think it bodes
well because again there's so many other
adventures out there and choices as well
as being associated in a certain group
for that in that way is also what the
younger generation doesn't like they'd
rather be associated with a variety of
endeavors and the versatility of doing
other endurance events right so like
being an Ironman athlete is kind of like
having a job in the madman era and and
now the freelance economy gig economy
young people and they're who they're
gonna be doing all different kinds yeah
that's exactly they'll be able to do an
Ironman and an ultra run and an
adventure race and you know it's like
why would we put a full year of training
into something that we already know the
outcome too right that's the hardest
part for a lot of endurance athletes I
can already close my eyes and see myself
crossing that finish line of an Ironman
I've done it before and they're all the
same so therefore I would rather apply
my time my dollars and all those
weekends to something that is unfamiliar
to me too that is more creative or more
scary or more dangerous or more
instagram-worthy
or again like we've just got to be real
I mean we're gonna do a lot of these
adventures for the coolness factor and
that coolness factor in my opinion will
run out with an Ironman after a while
yeah it's gonna be interesting to see
yeah I think that well I've already seen
the numbers be quite flat in their
growth actually I'm not negative really
but sort of flat
but you know they they came the 70.3
series is what really grew them so
quickly because it became way more
approachable less training hours so in
your experience of competing at a very
high level over many decades and your
experience working with so many athletes
over the years what can you distill from
all of that in terms of the mindset
principles or the habits or practices
that you've employed and that the
successful athletes that you've worked
with have employed to great benefit like
are there can you can you can an eyes
like the things that you've seen work
for yourself and the athletes that you
work with that seem to come up time and
time again I would say the longevity
aspect of it is what works best overtime
for the athletes and of course longevity
and overtime but what I mean by that is
that the athletes that have the most
success and can last the longest in the
sport because a lot of this is out last
thing too is the ones that truly enjoy
the training the journey the self
exploration nature outdoors daily self
care and so forth those that are just
focused on an outcome on a placing on a
time they do not last long in the ultra
endurance world right and I've noticed
it for myself but a lot of the athletes
that I coach if they have certain
numbers or times in mind for their
whether it's an Ironman or other events
that are measured and they don't achieve
it that frustration just grows and those
that love the activity the fitness the
health benefits the joy of doing it the
outdoors or the adventure with it those
seem to progress naturally and they're
out there now how come driven their
process driven and you know we hear that
in all kinds of facets of life not being
outcome driven being more process driven
and it works really really well and all
endurance athletics because again
there's too much that can happen on that
day and in that event when it whether
it's many days or one day that will
affect your outcome but if you already
enjoyed the process the journey so call
it then you're already ahead of the game
and you're winning so what do you do if
you're working with an athlete who's
very outcome driven to try to nudge them
or cajole them into being more process
driven well the important piece there is
to understand that they may choose to do
this every day right back off a little
bit and realize and look at yourself and
realize this is your choice every day
now I understand if your choice is to be
outcome driven but you can only do your
best right if you compare constantly to
others you're stuck in this quagmire of
constantly having to do better and
better and better and you will out that
will out pota that will push out the joy
and your best because you will never
achieve that right and so the more I can
work with them realizing that family and
career
and this whole choice of doing this it's
their hobby not their career it's not
their identity that then I can gradually
move them into more enjoying the process
and quite honestly I've lost a lot of
clients because of this over the years
right because they we don't see eye to
eye on this and not every workout is
gonna fit perfectly in line to the
outcome in four months from now like
you're going to have bad workouts you're
gonna have bad weeks you might even have
a bad month or two but we're doing the
work and we feel good about it and we're
enjoying it and this is what I would be
doing today anyway so accept that and
you're always learning as well right if
you're in the process you're learning
about your nutrition you're learning
about your mindset you're growing you're
you're already a better person than you
were yesterday right
oh is that um that quote you know you
never step in the same river twice
because the rivers changed and you've
changed right it's always a different
river and so that's what training in the
process is you are never going to be the
same person as you were yesterday
there's something you learned in that
work
about yourself about your Fitness about
your mind about your nutrition I can
spin that into 20 different angles of
why you're a better version and so what
do you think is is the hardest lesson
that you've had to learn in this
evolution from you know super ly Olympic
German precision driven you know Fitness
machine into you know masters athlete
and coach like what was the hardest
piece of advice that you had to digest
for yourself that the path isn't linear
right voice for me and you know from a
swimming background everything seemed to
fit orderly into a linear progression if
I do this work these yards this training
sure not every single lap but over the
weeks and months mm-hmm
the outcome will come no matter what
well it's such a controlled environment
I mean the world of ultras ultra running
versus swimming is you know yeah I guess
they're both you know individual sports
that are have some level of endurance
but a pool is the pool is always the
same standards it's like you couldn't
control an environment more you know
completely than swimming sport and so
yeah it must happen to that precision
mindset of like I do these things this
is the time I need to do yeah and I used
to coach like that with regards to
saying if you put in the work the
results will come I guarantee it and I
had to accept that that doesn't always
work we're all human beings and life
gets in the way but if you it depends on
your time window though right your time
window sure I mean we could we could
always play that super long window but I
also want assets to understand that you
know because it doesn't line up like
that you might be you might have
different goals in 18 months from now on
different interests and different
priorities and so hopefully you're
enjoying the training and healthy
lifestyle versus just must complete race
in X amount of time otherwise are not
good course you're good you have four
kids you were
it's 60 hours a week and then you're
fitting in this training
that's amazing there's not a lot of
people that are doing that but you're
comparing yourself to the guy who's a
lifeguard and has no kids and has you
know works out all day right like yeah
and so we're stuck in this world of what
were constantly comparing well these
guys do have our men in under five hours
if I don't do it under five hours I'm
not really good sure if you look at it
black and white on paper like that yeah
but they don't work like you do or have
family commitments like you do or you
know volunteer at the church like you do
or you know Sicilian things you can pick
at mm-hmm and so was there a specific
moment in your athletic career where you
had to meet your maker with that well I
mean I saw it with Iron Man triathlon
quite honestly I mean I didn't win my a
drupe in Hawaii for many years despite
knowing that I should be able to but
there's too many factors that come into
play and too many outcomes that I'm not
in control of or that little difference
was the difference between second third
and fourth and fifth and sixth ahead
every place in the time over ten years I
had Omaha but yeah it wasn't that easy
to just say I've put in the work I've
seen the numbers I know I can hold this
wattage I know I can run this pace it's
not gonna give me that result right
actually I had to let go and just sort
of train truly for the fun of it and the
joy of it in order to win my age group
in Hawaii right that's the lesson right
when you finally were compelled to let
go is when you have the success that had
eluded you know relied on others I mean
I had friends who said no this year
we're gonna train differently let's go
to adventures let's go do cool rides in
cool different places and create this
training that was completely different
that when all the years of structure in
May I must be doing this and then
therefore in August I'll feel like this
and then therefore in Hawaii no we did
it completely differently and we trained
differently and that was what I mean
right
how many
athletes from your generation of
professional triathlon Ironman are still
getting after it a lot yeah not a lot
there's still I mean there's still some
you know the Ken gloss of the world
still doing Hawaii but yeah there's I
mean again I'm not sure what other
adventures they've stepped into but many
of them are still active in some way
yeah but not racing or looking for the
the next adventure the way all right all
right we got to wrap this up but let's
let's leave all the athletes and
aspiring athletes that are listening and
watching with a couple takeaways to fuel
the spring months to come yeah well I
mean we came out of the winter with some
strength work and hopefully we're on a
stronger platform but because of those
hours and those reduced hours over the
winter hopefully were healthy and fresh
and ready to go but one thing I would
tie in is set up these training
adventures that I just talked about look
at your calendar and see maybe a
Memorial Day weekend or a July 4th
weekend and create something exciting or
a mini event that you yourself or your
friends or your family and you do to
create a training we can enjoy the
fitness that you've built and could been
consistent about over the last month's
weeks whatever it is and enjoy it with
your community right that's something I
try to tell my athletes all the time
create your own adventure even if you're
on a path to something that you've
already signed up for that was a really
cool weekend or I took a trail that I
never take and I ran down it for an
extra hour and a half and I saw corners
of my park that I never see right or run
to a location last year I was getting
ready for hello and other events and I
ran 40 miles in one direction to a town
that I usually cycle through stayed
there overnight great restaurants cool
little places and then ran back the next
day I know that's a little edgy for you
yeah but what I'm signing back 40 days
create the adventure I like
run 10k or bike somewhere or you know
bike somewhere swim the next day bike
the third day back or so you know so
that's what I I don't like to have too
many structured aspects to my training I
like to create many adventures all the
time and I think if more people did that
and their community and understanding
their immediate environment better
they'll enjoy the training in a
completely different process again yeah
that was one of the things that you
encouraged me to do when I was training
for Ultraman is to you know when when
that long bike or that long run you know
a distance that I'd never done before
came up like to make it like create a
route that would be exciting and
interesting that would be a
point-to-point so a you know I can't
back out but also to make it like an
adventure in and of itself and I
remember I mean it was transformative
I'd I'd never you know run such a great
distance and I had that 40 month he was
a 40 mile run that you put on that on
that on the schedule and so I decided to
run from Venice to Point Dume and back
like a long PCH which is like not the
best advice in terms of like a road to
run on yeah but it made it like super
epic to like run along the beat like
because you could rap Mike because you
can see point did you know it was like
and I chant that that was like that
changed my life yeah you know to think
like wow I never would have thought I've
been able to do that rather than running
in circles or you know something like I
tell a lot of athletes on long bike
rides to ride to a lunch spot stop there
for literally an hour learn what that
feels like and then ride home
uh-huh like four hours one way sit
hydrate fuel enjoy yourself get
lethargic and then re-engage the ride
home and it's an adventure you know pick
a point on a map and explore you create
the coolest part about endurance
athletics is that you create Fitness
that you can apply on any type of
adventure
you're with your kids camping cool do
something around that right well you
hike in or you carry an extra load or
you're off getting stuff or you run to
the store to get them
a milkshake or something right and there
that whoa you did what or that you're
with friends at a high school reunion
and they want to do something cool and
you have the fitness to actually just
jump in right that's what I talked about
endurance Fitness that you have the
ability to take on adventures that come
up and just go do it
that's all-around fitness and that's
truly taking it to not just structured
events but like cool tidbits yeah that
is process not outcome exactly it is the
journey not the destination right it is
it is and I know it's cliche these days
but for understanding that for athletic
outcomes is quite important because you
will have a slimmer ating sort of
freeing experience with it cool all
right my friend as always great to talk
to you thank you for dropping the wisdom
oh yeah all the athletes out there come
back and talk to me anytime yeah let's
do more live events let's do more stuff
man yeah I love talking about this and
as all my hath lights and listen there's
no you know it's just I sit there on my
own podcast and talk for an hour and a
half and I have to stop myself
I know continue I like I said last time
like I don't know how you do that man
the weekly word yeah everybody check it
out if you want to go super down the
rabbit hole and get really granular on
these concepts that that Chris knows so
well specific to endurance multi-sport
training fitness lifestyle all of that
check it out
at AI MP coach on Twitter
ai MP coaching com sign up for his
newsletter you'll send you every month
tasty tidbits December 1 room January 1
I don't know if I'll make J and good
luck at Alaska man thank you
we'll get you out there yeah well gank
you gotta figure something out yeah
alright cool man
alright peace
[Music]